[Music]
you
please be seated
good afternoon and welcome to the annual
hooding ceremony celebrating the
commencement of this year's doctoral
recipients as in other parts of
commencement our emphasis this afternoon
is on beginnings and on the empowering
value of education to the graduates
today MIT faculty invest you with the
ceremonial hood that symbolizes your
membership in the Academy that select
group of men and women who have earned
the highest of academic degrees this is
an important passage you were students
you are about to become colleagues you
should be proud of your accomplishments
and also grateful to the family and
friends who have supported you to
achieve this status the faculty and I
look forward to long years of
association with you as fellow members
of the Academy and of the MIT faculty
you need not wear your hood for
identification purposes but you should
keep it handy for occasions when it is
the proper attire your hood is new to
you but it is part of an academic
costume that has evolved over centuries
the rules governing American academic
regalia go back to the 1890s but the
scholars gown has its origins in the
Middle Ages doctoral gowns are typically
black with velvet trim puffy sleeves
with three bands on each arm
in 1995 MIT adopted a silver gray gown
trimmed in cardinal red the cap is a
simple mortar board there is no standard
as to which side the tassel is worn at
MIT we award to
for doctors of philosophy red and gray
inside the MIT colors blue velvet
outside the blue velvet denotes success
and mastering the process of seeking
wisdom and truth for doctors of science
red gray and blue inside with yellow or
gold velvet outside who symbolizes the
high value and contributions of science
to humanity the hood for an HST PhD is
the same as for the MIT PhD the hood for
the Woods Hole ph.d is similar but adds
blue inside hoods used to be sir used to
serve as head covers shoulder capes or
bags for arms and one vestige of those
early days survives today at the very
bottom of your hood is a small sack
which is large enough for a small book a
large sandwich or an iPod in a moment
MIT 16th President dr. Susan Hockfield
will offer you her own words of welcome
to the Academy following the president's
remarks you will proceed or we will
proceed with the investiture of hoods
our readers this afternoon are dr. Ike
Cobert MIT is Dean for graduate students
professor emeritus J Kaiser special
assistant to the chancellor and dean
Alice gasps vice president for research
and associate provost the faculty
marshals will assist students in
proceeding to the stage and in
reclaiming their seats now it is my
pleasure to introduce to you president
Susan Hockfield
[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome to the newly
minted doctoral recipients welcome to
the Academy and to your families and
friends who have gathered here to
celebrate your achievements welcome to
MIT congratulations on this important
occasion this is a moment that
celebrates and marks the pinnacle of
academic achievement the culmination of
years of scholarship and research
involving countless days and nights in
the laboratory and the library the
employment of exacting methodologies and
insightful imagination and most
importantly the creation of new
knowledge the creation of new knowledge
is the central requirement for the
doctoral degree and to my mind it is
among the hardest of intellectual tasks
accomplishing this task adventuring into
the realm of the as yet unknown can at
times be a lonely and even a terrifying
experience but each of you has ventured
successfully into that new land you have
expanded the base of human knowledge
each in your own field as scholars
before you have done for centuries in
doing so you have prepared yourselves
for lives and careers of discovery that
is a precious gift a gift to your chosen
field a gift to the Academy and a gift
to the world but perhaps the greatest
gift is you you have developed the
skills the understanding and the wisdom
to make important contributions to the
world as difficult and as frustrating as
working against the unknown can be it is
rewarding beyond measure the remarkable
and wonderful paradox of Advanced Study
or we could call it advanced
intellectual adventure
the remarkable paradox is the personal
reward of pursuing one's personal
intellectual aspirations and at the same
time and by the very same work
contributing to the betterment of
humankind it may not be entirely
paradoxical but neither is it entirely
obvious that the product of indulging
one's intellectual passion can improve
the human condition make no mistake in
understanding the potential of your
hard-won new skills because the world
needs you as it never has before
think of some of the challenges before
us the development of sound energy
technologies and policies for the
developing and for the developed world
making the discoveries that can fuel the
innovation economy understanding the
brain and the mind to tackle unremitting
diseases improving health through
advances in the converging disciplines
of the life sciences and engineering
advancing scientific literacy building
stronger communities and more livable
cities the list could go on and it does
but together with the perpetual drive to
understand better the farthest reaches
of our world there are more than enough
challenges to go around but wherever you
choose to put your intellect and your
talents to work in the Academy in
business or an industry or in government
service know that you have joined an
extremely select and extraordinary
company you have not only reached the
edge of your discipline you have pushed
the boundaries further you have invented
new ways of thinking about age-old
problems you have created new tools for
exploration in the process you have
taught junior colleagues in the
classroom and the lab and you have
enriched the MIT community in countless
ways we're grateful to your families and
your friends for the support they have
given you over these past several years
as I hope you have learned in your time
here MIT is as past president Paul Grace
has said a special place a place that
values deeply the life of the mind and
the exploration of the limits of our
universe through your experiences here
you have become part of MIT and we hope
that you will continue to consider MIT
to be your community your alma mater
your intellectual home welcome to the
community of scholars and
congratulations on your success
[Applause]
Thank You president Hockfield and now as
our honored doctoral recipients began to
come forward you have a moment to
reflect once again on the great
achievements and anticipate the joys yet
to come for what they will give the
world
we will now invest the candidates with
their hoods for the degrees of Doctor of
Science and Doctor of Philosophy in
School of Architecture and planning
representing the department of
architecture and assisting chancellor
clay is professor adel in santos for
Doctor of Philosophy glair D Anderson
Carlos our Barrios
[Applause]
axel Killian
go Helio palomero arias
[Applause]
Christine a walker representing the
department of urban studies and planning
professor Lawrence J Vale for Doctor of
Philosophy Jill in black house boy W
fuller re B Gelman Malo a Hudson Pia M
Cola Jung Hyun Lee Rodrigo
Serrano Bertha
[Applause]
Sunil tank on Pericles Zagros
representing the program in media arts
and sciences professor Mitchel Resnick
for Doctor of Philosophy Eric J
Blankenship our jell-o's Abe lets us
more varied in food Jenna H frost
Tristan jehanne
Aashish couple war Hugo you Jackie
mallet
Cameron Marlow
Alexandra masala k--
Paul nemirovsky James M Patton
Benjamin age wrecked
Andrea L Tomasz
in the School of Engineering
representing the department of civil and
environmental engineering professor
Patrick ja4 Doctor of Science Georges
Chakra Psilakis for Doctor of Philosophy
Ramachandran dollar Krishna Bihari
Benji Benji Molly vaneeta Molly excuse
me we're at chat the wrong
Giorgio's constantan Edie's
Susan see done
Jennifer M father Valeri
why even off Corrine s Koran bharath ke
Krishna sang-hyun Lee
Xiao Han Lin Jean Louise II look Sanna
Sanna chip Perino
you are jus representing the department
of mechanical engineering professor
Nicholas M Patrick Eliquis for doctor of
science
Brendon a Harley for Doctor of
Philosophy
Brian W Anthony Qingdao Benjamin s
Connell George II Craig
Christopher E Danes mark M Graham UNK
Kim Michael Jay King Kevin our lang
Sun woo Lee Jeremy a Levitan Chumlee
[Applause]
Richard C Montes aunty Ethan M Parsons
Jean Sebastian plant ocean jugni Singh
Yvonne's Khopoli when young son
Danielle see tariffs Anton F Thomas
[Applause]
Qian Tian Yugi way
Andrew K Wilson Joseph S long Shinyoung
Namek K illness
shinu John
li Jing representing the Department of
material science and engineering
professor Edwin L Thomas for the degree
of Doctor of Science
mark L Richard for Doctor of Philosophy
Nava Arielle
[Applause]
Simone C bellum our heal Benoit Ian beta
lieutenant boon young man arrived from
eel in capital Jorge white spire
Chirag Gupta kiseop came
he died Kim Trustin pili yi-jeong lock
Victor T nu Yin Xiu Yin Pok Juanita pong
sax Awad Ashley P praedyth's
[Applause]
Daniel case pelisson Jennifer M Vandiver
Jeong Jeong Eun Bo Jo
representing the Department of
Electrical Engineering and computer
science professor Eric L Grimson for the
degree of Doctor of Science
Petros buffoon oz Avon chela Novick
Fang Zhang
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Philosophy
in var Oberg
Bryan P Adams
Michael moiez a fair gun
Marius a Alberta
Mihai Bedoya Magdalena Bala's in sky JDP
burden
Stanley Valesky
Raoul blasquez Fernandez David B brown
Thomas P Berg hunts call about our Eric
Caulfield
[Applause]
Misha checkup
Li Wei Chen Xiang Yun Chao Michael H
Cohen Todd P Coleman
[Applause]
Eric Cosman
frank e de Becque shun my gosh
[Applause]
super no dice
Brian see demske Shahab Elba I and II
fun is not here Edward a Phyllis Co is
not here
what's his name
oh you scream stir that are you ready
Nick
Nicholas G Finster let's hear it
Edward a Phyllis Co Kevin foo Felix
Broward
[Applause]
Robert a turn Brian a hanger so Lou hop
shan-yuan whole andreas G Hoffman
Susan our Hoenn burger
Frances a honor a shin who Everest w
Hong jinho Joe John John
ro Nilda Luxan
Samuel B Larsen Harry Lee Janice see Lee
[Applause]
been W Lyon
Karen Levesque Oh
[Applause]
Leandro em Lauria Desmond s London chain
long Albert MA
Connor F Madigan Alexandra machina
[Applause]
Allan K mu 1 C Montoya Kota Murali
Stephen Peters on the pub Sri Devi
saaremaa
[Applause]
Darryl each liquor
jörg children
[Applause]
Florent Sigourney sudipta Sengupta T
Mateen says game
Gregory schockner ovitch Nathan our
sneed not Han Xu Travis el Simpkins Mark
Stevenson
[Applause]
Erik be Sudduth goo goo on Edward saw
Michael son
Godfrey ton Marshall F happen Maziar
atomically dusty air D Stanley trêpa
Tintin
Jessica H sane do we Tucker
Stephen Weiss
Justin Verl
guangrong er Heymann young
jinke you Michael are some Leela's are
lying representing the Department of
Chemical Engineering
professor Robert C Armstrong for the
degree of Doctor of Philosophy Hal s
Alper Brian J Anderson magic are
antonovitch Roger L Aaron OH
Kelvin John Patrick a demand Andre Beach
[Applause]
young song dole Arthur see gold site
sayyida M Jafar
Kyle L Jensen Jeremy see Johnson Jason
G crawl Catherine II Miller
[Applause]
Edward our Murphy Samuel s 9 Frederick
none tone
Scott David Phillips
Jason M plugger Gregory s polyp are
Michael Rob Greg see Randall Llewellyn
Bentley Richardson the third Heather a
stern
Hyrum tongue James W Taylor
Matthew Singh Wang Joanna you gu yong
representing the Department of
aeronautics and Astronautics professor
Wesley L Harris for the degree of Doctor
of Philosophy Giuseppe Alessio Sean D
Bradshaw
toe jam
Philip a Ferguson
Damien B Jordan
Sudeep Kumar Lahiri faman lay James C
loom roshan oak Neil Jionni
[Applause]
Elwin see on Haley
J Davison Reynolds Tom scouring ours a
friend Siddiqui
chae-young Joey tile Scott a Huebel
heart David Willis
[Applause]
representing the Department of nuclear
science and engineering is Professor Ian
H Hutchinson for the degree of Doctor of
Philosophy polar couple aro dong dong
Feng Michael R folkert Timothy P grades
Jing Li tiger
john ii Liptak jr. Lilu yun Leo Thomas H
Newton jr. suddha sattva Sinha
[Applause]
wrong one young ciao
zhang representing the biological
engineering division professor Douglas a
laughing burger for the degree of Doctor
of Philosophy
bump-bump ITV jayam young odda ow
Jonathan B Fitzgerald Albert je crois
Siddhartha Jane Ellen car sure min-soo
no V cos Prabhakar
James a rake strong rules Bay our tag
easy
Benjamin J second shin feng Joel
representing the engineering systems
division
professor David H marks for the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy Jia Jin Cheng oh
it's not here
however Heidi David's is Erica R Fuchs
Ralph P Hall
[Applause]
Konstantinos Calero's Christine being
Adam M Ross
eun-suk soon Heung whay drew my name is
Jay Kaiser
please remember that name you may never
hear it again
in the School of Humanities Arts and
Social Sciences representing the
department of economics professor bang
Holmstrom for the Doctor of Philosophy
David s Abrams Elizabeth oh uh Nana
Michael L Andersen Herman Z Bennett
Thomas Cheney
Francisco a Gallego Todd a Gormley
Veronica Guerrieri
jung jun-hwan there @e Kerwin David a
matzo
Marik PT PTT SIA Arturo Ramirez Verdugo
Veronica e-wrap a poor tally regev kcg
Rothschild
Jonathan L Weinstein below age Xia
representing the Department of Political
Science
Professor Charles H Stewart the third
for the Doctor of Philosophy Rachel the
cob
[Applause]
David M kanisky Marcela a not elegio
mark Z Taylor representing the
Department of linguistics and philosophy
professor Irene our Heim for the Doctor
of Philosophy
Annie coach Irma's Justin M Fitzpatrick
[Applause]
John our guy up ski he junco Joseph a
Sabah show ichi takahashi
[Applause]
Michael Wagener representing the program
in science technology and society
professor Michael Fisher for the Doctor
of Philosophy win who quo in the Sloan
School of Management representing the
Sloan School of Management professor
Stephen D Epping jur for the Doctor of
Philosophy Kevin J Boudreau Sushil RL
Natasha in is Condor Adam Seacole
ocinski Nicola latchet era
Kareem are Lakhani Igor Makarov
Hashmi r-rahman dad
Maria el Sousa
jegging Jang Michael Chang
representing the program in operations
research professor James B Orlan for the
Doctor of Philosophy elody edita Michel
Agassiz
[Applause]
Shoaib it Gupta
Susan me Martin Oh see Lauren McCann
[Applause]
Carol Myers
Alexander B Nogueira Guillaume rolls
Michael R Wagner pinku
in the school of science representing
the department of chemistry professor
Timothy M swagger for the Doctor of
Philosophy Michael D Altman sear on all
to nada
John P R Maura
Kevin W Anderson Julian Bachmann Emily
see Carson
the entire Qian Jing young chin chin
grace Chu
xavier e Horta
David L lar David s lighter me he limb
lured Poh Lopez
William L Neely Elizabeth M Nolan
Benjamin J Paxton p tirtir i'm i'm right
on sue sinha Daniel J Solis
Jonathan s Steckle
Ryan L Tom
Samuel W Thomas the third charns sac
tongue horn Klebe Walter w-where Matthew
a right
representing the Department of Biology
professor Chris Kaiser for the Doctor of
Philosophy jennifer michelle black
Achtung Myra a KU fall
Catherine EDA keno
Alexander WN swinger Shannon elf law PHP
Gupta
Greg L Hirsch andreas ho bogging
Junko Mahara ting Sharon L Kara cat
Kevin ly-one Qing m li Christian P
Peterson mark Rosen's bike
Christina M Taylor
Jessica D title
Jessica L whited joycie yang
representing the department of physics
professor mark a Kastner for the degree
of Doctor of Science
Ronit J by for the degree of Doctor of
Philosophy buh-bye
Stephon w Ballmer John Paul Opie Carosi
Shroff K Chatterjee
Connor Anderson
and wreak a Hennis Rosa
Christopher econ clue it's Keith s Lee
Aaron J machine on
Matthew W Mueller spa
[Applause]
Brian L pet
one mperatures Oh
[Applause]
Peter T raikage Thiago see Ribeiro
Antonello Scotty Keo Lonardo sanatory
[Applause]
Jesse Shelton young-shin
cloudy l stand
Chauncey stava Gary a steel Kai Winn Xu
hai tang yang Qi Zhong
Jing Zhu
representing the department of brain and
cognitive sciences professor Matthew a
Wilson for the degree of Doctor of
Philosophy Daniel J casa santo Itamar
Khan Boris
Krupa way Chung a li si ma a overed LAN
Alexander Rocklin
Richard Russell
Thomas are sorry
Douglas LG Olmec the very popular
Douglas J jar all mad
Susan D Kern more Edie long and T new
yen
Cameron wo bus
representing the department of
mathematics professor Michael F sip sir
for the degree of Doctor of Philosophy
Nathaniel L Ackerman vaguely angel by
Alice s Chan Pok wing fog
Christina M Goddard Deon K Harmon
Raymundo Helwani
Michael a hill
John our Hopkinson david l who Ludmila
cake a manova
and with a flip we moved to the next
again lewd will who Ludmila a cabin over
you are not expected to flip
bo Luke Kim fool you
Bianca Santoro
Benjamin K Stephens
Bridget ee tenor
David P venner
Daniel J Vera
juseong the Dean of Graduate Studies at
the Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution
dr. James a Yoder for the degree Doctor
of Philosophy
rosemarie he came me young s cook Donal
P extend
why Chiang Lee
sherry Al Simmons
Helen K white
Joshua D Wilson
Rachel J Vishnu ski
okay in the Whitaker College of Health
Sciences and technology representing the
division of Health Sciences and
Technology professor Martha L gray for
the doc for Doctor of Philosophy Gil
Altair events
Bradford C Bacchus
and R&B Baker
once on joy
David M Cochran
Paul M George
Rotter colore
[Applause]
kinuko Misaki
Alisa as Morris
shall mean mode
Laura J O'Donnell
david ii O'Gorman
[Applause]
Becky be poom
Chandran be such a Giri
daelin shin
Zachary and Smith
Jocelin isang ER and last but by no
means least sharon quo
[Applause]
our tradition for closing this ceremony
is though is to ask the faculty to stand
and give a hearty salute to our new
colleagues
[Applause]
the faculty and stage assembly will
recess after the faculty departs the
degree candidates do not recess but will
join the faculty and their families for
a reception at the Johnson Athletic
Center first floor for a reception the
[Music]
Johnson center is adjacent to this
building thank
[Applause]
[Music]